est il en droit de pêcher jusqu'à midi
et ensuite en ferme complètement les
temps la pêche
laurent a déjà pêché une carpe et s'est
installé avant l'arrivée des artificiers
depuis 10h raphaël déballe le matériel
une de ses principales préoccupations la
sécurité alors les contraintes
particulières ça va être la distance de
sécurité des produits donc là on a des
bons mois des compactes ça va être
chaque produit en fait à sa distance de
sécurité est donc la première contrainte
ça va être de mettre la zone sous
protection pour pas que des personnes
extérieures qui viennent sur le terrain
pendant qu'on est en train d'installer
les conditions météo sont bonnes
deux employés municipaux l'aide à tout
mettre en place
on a une 75 par trois éventail et comme
celles ci n'ont donc du coup il va
manquer ça la journée pour installer
l'ensemble du dispositif avec les bons
dans les mortiers les chandelles sur les
paniers en faire alors on a une conduite
de tir donc nous on retranscrit en fait
ce que le concepteur a imaginé et donc
on le retranscris sur le terrain pour
réussir à à donner vie à son idée en
quelque sorte les différents éléments
doivent être installés avec précision
pour respecter le dessin larchitecture
du feu d'artifice
le budget c'est moins de 5000 euros mais
s'est fait entre trois et cinq mille
pour un beau feu on a la chance de cette
année de travailler à écrêter feu qui a
l'art de faire des feux en musique
donc on va pouvoir synchroniser le feu
va être synchronisé avec une musique on
a choisi
pour ce spectacle pyrotechnique de 2015
musique classique avec ramon et haendel